but i watched this documentary on hulu
about the tekashi 69 kid yes and what's
so
[ __ ] shocking about that is that he
had at the same time he had like
five
hit songs on the like
billboard 100.
he's got all this money coming in
and he's just cutting people out of his
business who are like heavy [ __ ] shot
callers
in in like serious
[ __ ] gang [ __ ] and like
just from my experience when
when money's coming in and then you tell
someone hey you're off my team man i'm
not going to commission you anymore oh
yeah no that's
that was the most fascinating thing
about that how he thought he was going
to pull that off smoothly especially
especially the dudes that like you know
first at first funded him and put them
under his pain and gave him that
protection
and you know
i'll say this you know in in terms of
marketing himself
whether you love him or hate him he's a
genius for how he flips absolutely um in
terms of the street [ __ ] yeah you know
he violated on many fronts um but
you know
it's
that situation is tough because it's
it's it's like
yeah you know he probably realized they
were digging in his pockets in such a
way that like he should have been
getting more
maybe as an artist and he felt like
now i'm getting all of this right it's
just crazy and then you know not to like
like even
talk [ __ ] or anything it's just fat it's
a fascinating story yeah it is
that's what i you know and i thought
that documentary was really impressive
too no doubt man it is because it shows
you the story of how he makes himself
did and and and kudos to the kid for
being a [ __ ] marketing genius oh yeah
you know like him him uh
telling on
on his partners and all that [ __ ] i mean
you know that's for other people to
judge i mean some people that that are
street folks are like nah that that just
doesn't fly that's against the rules
because if you're playing the game then
you know
right you know you know what the
possibilities are
and you have to be okay with that and
you gotta man up
if you're playing in the streets
and you're not gonna adhere to the rules
then yeah you're gonna have that target
on your back you know what i mean and
that's he's got to forever live with
police protection for right now you know
or
i don't know how long he's going to be
under witness protection or whatever but
i don't know how well he does under
witness yeah i don't know how effective
that that protection is well it's he's
okay for now
but he's a guy who who now has had light
and is used to it and wants it and seeks
it and can't let go of it for his own
good
because he keeps winning like people
that aren't gang bangers aren't street
folks they're like well yeah so what if
he [ __ ] ratted those people out i
mean they were [ __ ] with him they
were getting over on him they tried to
rob him they tried to they pistol yeah
they pistol-whipped him
they don't get
the the commitment you make in this life
they don't get that they're just fans
and you know yeah god bless them they
you know
realistically if you're a civilian yeah
you don't adhere to those same rules if
you're in the life you must if you don't
then
what what he did that causes a target on
your back happens and that you know he
he knows that that's why he's he's
living the way he is now but it's i know
it's eating him inside because he can't
be as free as he was in terms of going
out and causing a commotion and you know
stirring up the baby
the tougher part is man like uh i you
know being
exposed to the light being like you know
uh
like acquainted with the celebrity and
all the shine
and and uh and that but people won't
[ __ ] with them yeah and not for nothing
he had good songs
you don't
that's that's the [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
like for for as much as he annoyed
people he actually had talent yeah you
know and he constructed his character
and and made it pop as
the street [ __ ] that he got caught up in
sort of yeah it taints all that for sure
but as an artist he was doing his thing
i mean was it my cup of tea i wasn't
going out of my way to [ __ ] with it but
when i did hear it yeah that's cool he
had he had some [ __ ] yeah but it's just
all the other [ __ ] can you look past
that can you accept that
and you know my my old self
in terms of where i came from now that's
unacceptable
unacceptable man enough said it's called
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole and
if you go on amazon and type in stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're
ranked number 30 on all of amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on amazon and buy stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude